bob saget was surrounded by family and
friends as he was laid to rest at 65
years old itsy has learned that the
private memorial service for the beloved
comedian was held in los angeles on
friday when you care about somebody
especially now i'm finding you got to
let them know along with bob's wife
kelly rizzo a number of the late actors
full house co-stars were in attendance
including mary kate and ashley olson
candace cameron beret
john stamos dave coulier lori laughlin
and more
these kids on full house basically the
characters are loaded they've got
everything their hair is always done
they always look great and they got
three guys raising them pretty much and
their aunt becky and there's a million
people there's 14 people in the house
full house is about tax deductions
that's what it is as many people as you
can cram into a small space norman lear
dave chappelle and john mayer are
included in the famous faces who came to
pay their respects
john mayer even served as a paw bearer
according to tmz at least 300 people
attended the memorial service to honor
bob's life ladies and gentlemen jesse
and the rippers and me i'm danny tanner
ahead of the service bob's on-screen
best friend john stamos took to twitter
to share how he was feeling he tweeted
quote today will be the hardest day of
my life
god grant me the serenity to accept the
things i cannot change courage to change
the things i can and wisdom to know the
difference
in the day before the memorial service
john mayer shared this video to
instagram of himself and comedian
jeffrey ross picking up bob saget's car
at lax
everyone is so aware how universal
bob's love for people
was
in the video the singer opens up about
how bob had a special gift for making
everyone feel loved so much so that they
felt as if they were a main character in
his life
bob's effusive
and repeated expression of love
is the greatest gift
that he left people
because all we have is the pain
of his going and and we don't
have to worry
about the accounting the affairs are in
order
in terms of wondering or not having to
wonder how bob felt about us do you know
what i mean
you